it's nice for those incentives to be
transparent so
for example i'll give i'll give you
examples there seems to be a significant
uh distrust of um
a tech
like entrepreneurs in the tech space or
or people that run for example social
media companies like mark zuckerberg
there's not a complete transparency of
incentives under
which that particular human being
operates
the tren you know we can listen to the
words he says or what the marketing team
says for a company but we don't know
and that's that's becomes a problem when
that
the algorithms and the systems created
by
him and other people
in that company start having more and
more impact on society
and that it starts you know if if the
incentives were somehow the definition
and the explainability of the incentives
was um
decentralized such that no nobody can
manipulate it
no propaganda
uh type manipulation of
like how these systems actually operate
could be done then yes
it would be not it i think i think ai
could achieve um
much fairer much more effective
uh
sort of
uh like solutions to to difficult
ethical problems but when there's like
humans in the loop
manipulating this the
the dissemination the communication of
how the system actually works that feels
like you can run into a lot of trouble
and that's why there's currently a lot
of distrust for for people at the heads
of companies that have increasingly
powerful ai systems
i suspect what happened traditionally in
the u.s was that since our decision
making is much more central and
decentralized than in an authoritarian
state right people are making decisions
autonomously at many many levels in a
society what happened that was
we created coherence and cohesion in
society by controlling what people
thought and what information they had
right the media synchronized public
opinion
and social media have disrupted this
it's not i think so much russian
influence or something it's everybody's
influence it's that a random person can
come up with a conspiracy theory and
disrupt what people think
and if that conspiracy theory is more
compelling or more attractive than the
standardized public conspiracy theory
that we give people as a default
then it might get more traction right
you suddenly have the situation that a
single individual somewhere on a farm in
texas has more listeners than cnn
which particular farmer you're referring
to in texas
i probably know
yes i had dinner with him a couple times
okay
right this is an interesting situation
because you cannot get to be an anchor
in cnn if you don't go through a
complete
complicated gatekeeping process and
suddenly you have random people without
that gay keeper process uh just
optimizing for attention
not necessarily with a lot of
responsibility for the long-term effects
of
projecting these theories into the
public and now there is a push of making
social media more like traditional media
which means that the opinion that is
being projected in social media is more
limited to an acceptable range with the
goal of getting society into safe waters
and increase the stability and cohesion
of society again which i think is a
laudable goal but of course it also is
an opportunity to seize the means of
indoctrination
and the incentives that people are under
when they do this
in such a way that
the ai ethics that we would need
becomes very often
something like ai politics which is
basically partisan and ideological and
this means that
whatever one side says another side is
going to be disagreeing with right in
the same way as when you turn masks or
the vaccine into a political issue if
you say that it is politically virtuous
to get vaccinated it will mean that the
people that don't like you
will not want to get vaccinated right
and as soon as you have this partisan
discourse it's going to be very hard to
uh make the right decisions because the
incentives get to be the wrong ones ai
ethics needs to be super boring it needs
to be done by people who do statistics
all the time and have extremely boring
long-winded discussions that most people
cannot follow because they are too
complicated but that are that serious
these people need to be able to be
better at statistics than the leading
machine learning researchers and at the
moment
the ia ethics the debate is the one but
you don't have any barrier to entry
right everybody who has a strong opinion
and is able to signal that opinion in
the right strong words
and uh to me this is a very frustrating
thing because the field is so crucially
important to us so crucially important
but
uh the only qualification you currently
need is to be outraged by the injustice
in the world
it's more complicated right there
everybody seems to be outraged but
wow so let's just say that the
incentives are not always the right ones
so basically i i suspect that
a lot of people that enter this debate
don't have a vision for what society
should be looking like in the way that
is non-violent where we preserve liberal
democracy where we make sure that we all
get along and uh we are around in a few
hundred years from now uh preferably
with a comfortable technological
civilization around us
you